WELCOME EVERYONE TO CNN
NEWSROOM, I APPRECIATE YOUR
COMPANY, I AM MICHAEL HOLMES.
WE BEGIN WITH BREAKING NEWS
FROM AFGHANISTAN, OR TALIBAN
FIGHTERS, HAVE NOW, CAPTURED 2
MORE KEY CITIES.
LASHKAR GOSH, AND KANDAHAR.
THE GROUP APPEARS TO BE HAVING
CELEBRATIONS IN KANDAHAR, AND
THEY CAN'T CONFIRM THE
TELEVISION VICTORY.
THEY SAY THAT THEY SEIZED
HUNDREDS OF WEAPONS, VEHICLES,
AND AMMUNITION, AS YOU CAN SEE
THERE.
AMERICAN SUPPLIED VEHICLES.
THE HEAD OF THE PROVINCIAL
COUNCIL, SAYING THAT THE ENTIRE
CITY IS UNDER TALIBAN CONTROL,
EXCEPT FOR THE AIRPORT, AND
ARMED RECALL.
IT APPEARS TO SHOW TALIBAN
FIGHTERS TAKING OVER GOVERNORS
BUILDINGS IN KANDAHAR, AND IT
APPEARS TO SURRENDER, OR FLEE.
THEY NOW GO OVER 14 PROVINCIAL
CAPITALS.
THEY NOW HAVE INTERNATIONAL
SECURITY EDITOR, NICK PATON
WALSH, IN LONDON.
YOU KNOW HAVE KANDAHAR, LASHKAR
GONE, AND JUST THE LATEST AND
STUNNING TURNS OF EVENTS.
SPEAK TO THE SITUATION AS KABUL
IS, INCREASINGLY, SURROUNDED.
>> IT IS IMPORTANT TO EMPHASIZE
THAT IT'S FALL, AS WE
UNDERSTAND IT, WITH THE
EXCEPTION OF ONE OR 2 ARMY
BASES, IS UNDER TALIBAN CONTROL,
IS DEEPLY SYMBOLIC MOMENTS.
KANDAHAR, OF COURSE, MASSIVELY
IMPORTANT.
BOTH LASHKAR, IN ITSELF, IS A
PLACE WHERE U.S., AND NATO
LIVES HAVE BEEN LOST.
IT IS A FOCAL POINT OF THE
OPIUM TRADE, THAT FUNDS THE
INSURGENCY.
THE FACT THAT THE AFGHAN
SECURITY FORCES PUT UP SUCH AN
INTENSIVE FIGHT, LAYING DOWN A
BUNCH OF THE COMMANDOES,
BECAUSE THEY KNEW THAT THEY
WOULD WANT TO HOW THAT
SYMBOLICALLY, AND THAT THEY
HAVE NOW LOST, ALONG WITH
KANDAHAR, IN THE SAME NIGHT, IT
APPEARS, IS ABSOLUTELY
STARTLING.
THAT LEAVES IT AMONG THE MAJOR
CITIES TO THE WEST, AND SOUTH
OF THE COUNTRY, UNDER TALIBAN
CONTROL.
PARTICULARLY, THE BIRTHPLACE OF
THAT MOVEMENT.
WE ARE ALSO NOW HEARING I,
WHICH IS NOW A SPARSELY
POPULATED PROVINCE, WHICH HAS
ALSO NOW FALLEN, AS WELL.
SO, IT IS LITERALLY A SLOW,
INCREASINGLY FAST DRUMBEAT OF
PROVINCIAL CAPITALS FALLING, AT
THIS POINT.
NOW, TO THE NORTH, THE CITY IS
UNDER PRESSURE, AND AN ECONOMIC
HUB THERE WHICH, CERTAINLY, WE
WILL HEAR MORE ABOUT.
ONCE YOU ARE HAPPENING IN THAT
AHEAD.
LUCKILY THEY POINT OUT, THIS
TURN FORECAST NOW TO KABUL, AND
THERE'S NO INDICATION THAT THE
CAPITOL, IS CURRENTLY, BEING
BESIEGED, OR UNDER THREAT.
BUT, IT'S INCREASINGLY
SURROUNDED, GEOGRAPHICALLY.
SO, WE ARE INTO AN
EXTRAORDINARY 2, TO 3 WEEKS
AHEAD, WHERE THE U.S. HAS NOW
STATED, THEY WILL PUT 3000
MARINES INTO KABUL
INTERNATIONAL AIRPORT, TO
SECURE IT, TO GET THE DIPLOMATS
OUT, TO LIKELY GET OUT SOME OF
THE TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
AFGHANS, WHO THEY SAID, MAKE IT
SPECIAL IMMIGRANT VISA STATUS.
AND AT THE END OF AUGUST, THEY
WILL LEAVE UNDER THE CURRENT
PLAN, THEY WILL ALTER, BUT THEN
THEY WILL SEE THE EXTRAORDINARY
DEPARTURE OF U.S. FORCES, AND
PERSONNEL, TO THE GREATEST
EXTENT, FRANKLY, AND THEN SEE
WHAT EXACTLY COMES AFTER THAT.
I HAVE TO SAY, IT IS STRANGE TO
SEE THE FORMER ALLY OF THE
AFGHAN GOVERNMENT, TO SAY THEY
ARE STILL THE ALLY, BECAUSE
THEY HAVE MOMENTS OF DEPARTURE,
THAT EMPHASIZED ALMOST BY A
VERY PRACTICAL, UNNECESSARY,
SECURITY FORCE FOR THAT
DIPLOMATS.
BUT, IT DOES SEND A MESSAGE, TO,
I THINK, AND TALKING TO SENIOR
AFGHAN OFFICIALS LAST NIGHT,
CERTAINLY, THE U.S. KNOWS WHICH
DIRECTION THIS IS LIKELY TO BE
GOING.
CERTAINLY, WITHIN THE SENIOR
U.S. AFGHAN OFFICIALS IS A
SENSE OF BETRAYAL, AND OF LOSS.
KABUL, BY NO MEANS, IS AN EASY
THING FOR THE TALIBAN TO WALK
INTO.
I WOULD HAVE TO SAY, ALL
CONVENTIONAL WISDOM IS OFTEN,
NO ONE THOUGHT THEY COULD SWEEP
THROUGH, IN JUST ONE WEEK.
THIS IS HOW THE NUMBERS ARE
INFLUENCING THE CAPITAL, BUT IN
KABUL, 6 MILLION PEOPLE, A LOT
VERY GOVERNMENT LAWYER, IT
COULD BE MESSIER, BUT WE DON'T
KNOW WHERE THIS WILL PLAY OUT,
MICHAEL.
>> IT'S INTERESTING.
I LIKE YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS.
IT'S ANOTHER PLACE IN THE
HEADLINES AS WELL.
AL-QAEDA HAD A LONG HISTORY
THERE.
OSAMA BIN LADEN, SEEING IT AS A
HATE SAFE HAVEN FOR HIS MEN.
WHAT DO YOU SEE AS THE RISKS OF
AN AL-QAEDA RESURGENCE?
THEY ARE FIGHTING SHOULDER TO
SHOULDER IN THE COUNTRY.
>> THERE IS OUR AFGHANISTAN,
THAT IS ESSENTIALLY CHANGES TO
THE POLICY AT THE TIME.
AND IN 2000, ONE THEY'RE ALL
OVER THE PLACE, AND THIS IS A
TRY TO WIND DOWN THE PRESENTS,
AIR AND DECLARE VICTORY, THERE
IS NOW A COOL OF HUNDREDS.
IT SEEMS TO, STILL, ROUGHLY BE
THE CASE.
AND IT IS PRETTY SENIOR PEOPLE,
AND IN OCTOBER LAST YEAR, AN
AFGHAN INTELLIGENCE RAID, WHERE
THERE IS A NUMBER 2.
VERY MUCH, THEY ARE IN CHARGE
OF PROPAGANDA, AND
COMMUNICATION.
HE WAS SAID TO BE COMMUNICATED
WITH OTHER AL-QAEDA CELLS IN
SYRIA, AND THERE APPEARS TO BE
A U.S. STRIKE WHERE, SHORTLY
AFTER THE POSITION WAS,
INTERCEPTED.
I WAS TOLD THAT AMERICANS, IN
FACT, HAD ASKED THE AFGHANS TO
NOT PUBLICIZE THEIR
ASSASSINATION, PRESUMABLY, SO
THEY COULD GET ON WITH ACTING
THE INFORMATION THAT THEY HAVE
FOUND.
THERE IS A PRESIDENT IN
AFGHANISTAN AND, AND THE CITY
YOU JUST REFER TO.
IT IS HARD TO DELINEATE IN THIS
CHANGING WORLD OF EXTREMISTS,
PRECISELY WHERE AL-QAEDA ENDS,
AND THE TALIBAN BEGINS.
ONE OF TALIBAN SENIOR
LEADERSHIP, BRINGING IN THE
NETWORK, AND INTO THEIR
AFFILIATE, INTO THE COMMAND
STRUCTURE.
SO, THE LINES ARE BLURRED, THE
TELEPHONICALLY THAN WANT
FOREIGNERS, OR TERRORIST.
THEY SENT A DEAL WITH THE USA
THAT THEY WON'T LET AFGHANISTAN
BE USED FOR ATTACKS ON FOREIGN
COUNTRIES.
BUT, IT IS A KEY, PRESSING
PROBLEM, AND ONE THAT, I THINK,
WE WILL HEAR MUCH MORE ABOUT
THAN WE DO NOW, IN THE YEARS
AHEAD.
.
>> YOU MENTIONED THE NETWORK
WHERE YOU GET TO SEE HOW THEY
MAY CLAIM ALL OF THIS TO.
GOOD TO SEE YOU NICK,
APPRECIATE THE ANALYSIS, THANK
YOU.
>> ALI IS A FREELANCE
JOURNALIST BASED IN AFGHANISTAN,
HE JOINS ME FROM KABUL.
ALI, THANK YOU FOR DOING SO.
I KNOW IT HAS BEEN DIFFICULT.
HOW ARE CONDITIONS IN KABUL?
THOUSANDS OF DISPLACED PEOPLE,
ARRIVING IN THE CAPITAL, AND
WITH THE LEVEL OF ANTICIPATION,
AND CONCERN.
>> IT IS LOOKING AT 5, OR 6 PM
LAST NIGHT, AND LIVING IN A
DIFFERENT COUNTRY.
THINGS HAVE CHANGED, OBVIOUSLY,
A LOT.
THE FACT THAT IRAQ, TO END
KANDAHAR, WERE LOST IN
ESSENTIALLY, THE SAME DAY, AND
2 OF THE BIGGEST CITIES IN THE
COUNTRY.
CITIES THAT PEOPLE, NEVER,
WOULD HAVE IMAGINED WOULD HAVE
FALLEN, AND IT WAS MY LAST HOPE
SAYING THAT IF YOU'RE GOING TO
TAKE OVER THE CITIES, THEY
WON'T MAKE IT MUCH FURTHER.
THEY WON'T MAKE IT INTO ANY BIG,
MAJOR POPULATION AREAS.
THEY'RE SEEING THEM MAKE IT
INTO THOSE CITIES, AND IF
YOU'VE BEEN TO THOSE CITIES
WHICH HAS BEEN HISTORICAL FOR
THEM, BUT SEEING THOSE VIDEOS,
AND THAT FOOTAGE, IT REALLY
AFFECTED PEOPLE.
IT AFFECTED THE WHOLE COUNTRY.
THERE ARE VERY FEW PEOPLE WHO
ARE ACTUALLY FROM KABUL.
THERE ARE PEOPLE WHO, HAVE
SPENT OVER DECADES HERE, AND
STILL, ALMOST EVERYONE'S FAMILY
COMES FROM SOMEWHERE ELSE.
AND YOU CAN SEE THESE PROVINCES
FALLING, BUT ALMOST EVERYWHERE,
PROBABLY, HAS SOME CONNECTION
TO ONE OF THOSE.
>> OUR AFGHANS WHO SPEAK WITH
ANGRY ABOUT THE SPEED OF THE
WITHDRAWAL OF THE WEST?
DO THEY FEEL LET DOWN, OR
ABANDONED?
NOT JUST BY THE WEST, BUT BY
THEIR OWN LEADERS, WHO HAVE
OFTEN, OF COURSE, IT ACCUSED OF
BEING CORRUPT, OR RUNNING THE
COUNTRY INEPT AWAY?
>> I WAS SPEAKING TO FRIENDS
FROM KANDAHAR LAST NIGHT, AND
THAT WAS EXACTLY WHAT THEY WERE
SAYING.
THEY WERE FEELING LIKE THERE
WASN'T MUCH OF A FIGHT PUT UP.
THEY FELT THAT THERE WASN'T
MUCH OF AN EFFORT TO PUT INTO
DEFENDING THE CITIES.
THAT THE CITY'S FELL TO EASILY,
AND TO QUICKLY.
CONSIDERING THEIR SIGNIFICANCE,
THEIR HISTORY, AND TO THE
POPULATION, INTO THE ECONOMY OF
THIS COUNTRY.
AND IT IS JUST EXPRESSING SO
MUCH FRUSTRATION AT THE
GOVERNMENT.
SO MUCH FOR ITS CORRUPTION, FOR
ITS INABILITY.
>> IS THERE A RISK FOR THE
TALIBAN, DOMESTICALLY, BUT
HAVING GOTTEN THEIR CHIEF
DEMAND, WHICH IS THE DEPARTURE
OF FOREIGN FORCES, AND THEN
CONTINUING THE FIGHT, AND
KILLING FELLOW AFGHANS MIGHT
BACKFIRE ON THE GROUP IN TERMS
OF WHATEVER GRASSROOTS SUPPORT
THEY HAD?
THEY AREN'T KILLING WESTERNERS
RIGHT NOW, THEY ARE KILLING
AFGHANS.
>> THIS IS EXACTLY WHAT PEOPLE
SAY.
THEY'RE FIGHTING AN OCCUPATION,
AND THEY'RE GOING TO LEAVE.
THEY HAVE BEEN AGREED, AND IT
IS THEIR FORCES, AND THEIR
ADMINISTRATORS, AND EVERYTHING
LIKE THAT.
AND, IN THE WAY THAT THEY HAVE
BEEN ACTING, OR THE WAY THEY
HAVE BEEN STORMING THROUGH THE
CITY'S, THEY HAVE ALSO LOST
THEM A LOT OF SUPPORT.
BECAUSE, IF YOU SEE HOW MANY
PEOPLE ARE FLEEING THE CITIES,
AND IF THEY HAD MET THEM WHEN
THEY CAME TO KABUL, WHAT
THEY'LL SAY IS WHEN THEY HEAR
THEIR ON THEIR WAY, WE KNOW
THEY ARE COMING IN A DAY OR 2,
AND WE WILL FLEE AS SOON AS WE
CAN.
THERE IS PLENTY OF THOUGHT
HERE.
THERE IS A LOT OF FEAR OF THE
FIGHTING THAT COMES WITH IT,
AND IF THEY COME, AND THAT
MEANS THAT THEY WILL BE
FIGHTING WITH THE SECURITY
FORCES, AND THE SECURITY FORCES
WILL BE FIGHTING WITH THEM.
WHO IS CAUGHT IN THE CROSS FIRE?
>> ALL OVER, THEY ARE KNOCKING
ON THE DOORS, OR THERE WILL BE,
SOON OF KABUL.
ARE YOU WORRIED, YOURSELF?
>> I AM WORRIED FOR MY PEOPLE.
I AM WORRIED FOR THE COUNTRY.
>> ARE YOU ANGRY AT HOW THIS
CAME TO BE?
>> YES.
BECAUSE --
BECAUSE I FEEL LIKE EVERYBODY
SHARES A RESPONSIBILITY.
>> ALI, THANK YOU SO MUCH,
THINKING OF YOU IN KABUL, AND
EVERYONE ELSE THERE AS WELL.
THEY ARE FOLLOWING YOUR TWITTER,
AND PEOPLE SHO